marco pedalea su bicicleta 70 veces por
minuto cuáles de estos son estimaciones
razonables sobre el pedaleo de marco
indica todas las posibles respuestas así
que pensemos en esto 70 veces en un
minuto hay 60 segundos en un minuto
cierto si él estuviera pedaleando 60
veces en un minuto entonces estaría
pedaleando una vez cada segundo pero
está pedaleando un poco más que eso
porque son 70 veces cada minuto así que
un poco más de una vez por segundo
entonces veamos la primera opción dice
marco pedalea su bicicleta
aproximadamente 4000 veces por cada
segundo es hasta de loco cierto porque
porque aquí acabamos de razonar sería
como 4000 por 60 segundos eso es
demasiado cierto acabamos de razonar que
que marco pedalea su bicicleta
aproximadamente una vez un poco más de
una vez cada segundo así que en
definitiva esta no es la correcta
ahora marco pedalear su bicicleta
aproximadamente una vez cada hora
tampoco
a razonable es cierto porque aquí
tenemos que el pedalea 70 veces cada
minuto en un total serían 70 x 60 él
iría muy lento ahora en la siguiente
marco pedalea su bicicleta
aproximadamente una vez cada segundo ya
habíamos razonado que hay 60 segundos en
un minuto y el pedalea 70 veces en un
minuto entonces si dividimos 70 entre 60
obtenemos un número un poco mayor que 1
así que sí sí sí es correcto esto es
cierto estamos haciendo estimación no
debe ser un número exacto es
aproximadamente una vez cada segundo así
que suena totalmente razonable esta
parece la correcta ahora marco pedalea
su bicicleta aproximadamente 4000 veces
cada hora pensemos en esta un poco si el
pedalea 70 veces en un minuto y hay 60
minutos cada hora entonces esto es igual
7 por 6 es igual a
es igual a 42 entonces 7 por 6 es igual
a 42 y tenemos dos ceros así que
exactamente cuatro mil doscientos cada
hora por lo tanto como estimación esto
se acerca bastante cierto así que
también me voy con esta respuesta y
bueno ya terminamos